yes it is date night here in new jersey
unless you know quite well late night
every night in my house
i'm a party don't think tonight
typical i couldn't have the vmas be in
new jersey and not represent right
without a doubt yes no but one place
where you didn't represent was at
teresa's recent nuptials so were y'all
invited and did you decide to forego
that invitation
i mean that's a long story yeah he's
just he just passes it right on over why
are you passing it off to your lady
because it's very difficult for me to
talk about it's hard it's very really
really it's really hard so
you know it's a rough situation it
really is and you know what i think
everyone will
see obviously because a lot of it was
filmed for the real housewives it's hard
to discuss right now so we can't really
discuss it but we wish them the best and
we're very happy and she looked
beautiful and it was a beautiful wedding
were you invited though
yes yes yes okay yes
yes family first yes you know so i hope
you guys can take care of whatever's
going on
tonight
[Music]